uh we're really taking that leap
us as a company buyer
in cell and gene therapy which to me is
one of these examples where really we're
going to make a difference hopefully
moving forward there's some
ultimately the the mrna vaccines are an
example for that cell and gene therapy i
always like to say if we had surveyed
two years ago
in the public would you be willing to
take a
gene
gene or cell therapy and injected into
your body we would have probably had a
95 refusal rate i think this pandemic
has also opened many people's eyes to to
innovation in the way that was maybe not
possible before
we're really taking that leap
okay
so what i wanted to do was address the
question there's obviously been a whole
lot of
ink spilled
over whether or not these are vaccines
or not vaccines whether this is gene
therapy or not gene therapy now i have
pretty much avoided those discussions
because my sense is
they are
um
strictly a semantic question you deliver
me the definition and i'll tell you
whether that's a vaccine you deliver me
the definition and i'll tell you whether
it's gene therapy and the problem is if
we say these vaccines are gene therapy
that will cause people to think that
they are a lot more dangerous and if we
tell people they're not gene therapy it
will cause people to think they're a lot
safer but in fact whether they are or
not does not adjust their level of
safety at all right
and
this is an important point right and
this is a point that gets muddled by uh
postmodernists rather intentionally i
think the idea that language itself
changes underlying meaning
language can change the meaning of
things but applying different language
to existing things
does not mean that that existing thing
is a or b depending on whether or not
it's got label a or b on it right and
it's a classic estate tax yeah people
are in favor of an estate tax because
you're taxing the rich death tax sounds
like you're kicking somebody when
they're down it's the same tax
so
anyway what i wanted to do was just give
people an orientation so they know what
the question is and you can answer for
yourself then whether or not this is
gene therapy but the point again is
it's been used as a political football
uh rather than it being uh
right and i think even though rather
than let's let's put it this way i think
the fact that one can argue it either
way is the answer to the question this
is something very new
it's so new that it does not clearly
fall within or outside the definition of
gene therapy and i want to just give
people enough information to understand
what is what is being described
so traditionally gene therapy which i
think initially goes back the idea is
sort of seeded in the 80s
it's a
it's a cool idea but i would say it's an
idea that is overly based in the drawing
in your textbook which is always
misleading right so if you think about
it
there are many disorders or diseases
that are the result of a gene being
broken in some way right your genes are
spelled in some way they produce
proteins mind you i will go back and
tell you that the word gene isn't very
useful genetic is a very useful term i
don't use the term gene very much but
i'll use it here just for shorthand
there are lots of cases in which a gene
has taken on a mutation that has
disrupted the production of its product
and made it harmful and if the product
let's say there's an enzyme that you
need to produce in your liver to
detoxify something and you have a bad
spelling of the gene that will interrupt
your ability to
uh produce the enzyme and to detoxify
the thing and if you encounter it that's
bad now in general
these things don't matter
every time because you have two copies
of every gene
and so you know in many cases even if
you have a bad spelling if you have a
good spelling um you'll be all right
but
when somebody comes into their doctor
and they have some kind of a malady
there's a fair percentage of the time
that it
is the result of the fact that they have
maybe gotten two bad copies of a gene or
it could be a sex-linked thing where
they only have one copy to begin with
and it's disrupted but nonetheless there
are lots of cases in which a badly
spelled gene disrupts your ability to do
something that is part of normal
functioning and it has left you
dysfunctional so of course
given all of the tools that nature has
built for editing
genes and
things like this
an obvious answer is well why don't we
just give you a good copy of the gene
and the basic answer to that question
and what i thought when we were uh first
hearing these ideas uh you know in
i guess we would have first heard them
in high school but college would have
been where they came up was well here's
the reason that that's not a great plan
it's that
you don't have a genome it's not like a
central thing that lives somewhere in
you that we can edit your 30 trillion
cells
and you know yeah maybe if it's a liver
gene that we're talking about you don't
need all 30 trillion cells modified you
probably don't need all
100 billion cells in your liver or
however many it might be several hundred
billion um cells in your liver but still
you've got to edit
awful lot of cells before you've done
enough work to actually solve the
problem even if the cells that you edit
work overtime
it's still a long way before you've done
anything therapeutic the genome is
highly centralized within the cell but
highly decentralized within the body
yeah that's well said
okay so
the point is what gene therapy basically
means is
or at least initially basically meant
was you go in you edit a gene so that
the bad product is replaced by a good
product and you're no longer sick or
you're less sick
the problem is
easier said than done right we do have a
lot of tools for editing genes you can
do it in a cell pretty easily you might
be able to deliver it with a syringe to
a particular tissue but how much uptake
you're going to get how much actual
useful editing you're going to get and
how much will you know maybe you edit a
bunch of things well but in the process
you also disrupt a bunch of things that
worked because the editing isn't perfect
right see
so anyway the point is really cool idea
really difficult to do okay
implementation is going to be tough yeah
implementation is tough now zach do you
want to
put up the
fda has a little explainer site uh what
is gene therapy and you can begin to see
what the problem is do we know if is is
this a modern
uh version of it and has it changed uh
in these last two this is the current
one i don't know if it's changed but
it's good enough if it's changed
it has not changed in the way actually
it says content current as of uh july
2018. okay so they haven't changed it
then at least if that's accurate
okay
so can you scroll down
okay stop um so there are a variety of
types of gene therapy products including
plasmid dna that is circular dna
molecules that can be genetically
engineered to carry therapeutic genes
into human cells so um
plasmids
are
outside of genomes they are little units
that carry particular instructions so
sometimes
antibiotic resistance in bacteria is
carried on a plasmid those plasmids can
be exchanged between critters
so that's
the introduction of it they're talking
here about introducing a plasmid that
contains a useful gene and not
integrating it into the genome
presumably
viral vectors now viral vectors are
capable in many cases of introducing
genes into a genome they can actually
edit things in that's one of the things
that many viruses do now it turns out
coronaviruses do not
but nonetheless viral vectors is a way
you could edit a genome
bacterial vectors bacteria can be
modified to prevent them from causing
infectious disease and then they can be
used as vectors to carry therapeutic
genes into human
tissues
now that suggests that they are not
editing
genes at all with their bacterial
vectors
anyway
well the point is this interesting i
wonder if that's an intentional use of
that word or if it's just
vagaries
i think the point is as with the word
gene right we defined we used to define
the word gene and we said oh a gene is
that which exists between a start codon
and a stop codon right and then it
encodes a protein we now know that
that's not true right there's something
like an average of five different edits
that you can make of what exists between
a start codon and a stop codon and so
each gene may have
multiple
productive interpretations right
you know i gotta say i uh this i've
never seen the site before and this list
of five so for those just listening
there's actually five bullet points and
you just read the first three
the fourth one is human gene editing
technology the goals of gene editing are
to disrupt harmful genes and repair
mutated genes
and it feels to me like this is this
should not be a uh unordered five bullet
point list but that um
plasma dna may be i know less about what
that might do but bacteria viral vectors
and bacterial vectors both could be used
to effect human gene editing technology
and indeed human gene editing technology
is the thing that people i think have in
their heads and they get scared about
when they hear gene therapy like that's
the thing they worry about most right
right and it's not like this is not
these aren't all equal it's like having
a list of hypotheses you're like no
those aren't alternatives to one of
these these five things don't strike me
as alternatives to one another even
though that's how it's being proposed
here well
i think the point is you start out with
an idea people have bad genes that
causes disease we'll edit those genes
and make them good okay then you realize
ah
that's difficult but there are a lot of
things we can do in that neighborhood
that might work
right like we could put maybe we don't
have to edit the genome maybe we'll put
it on a plasmid and we'll introduce the
plasmids and maybe we'll have to do it
periodically but you'll still be better
right
um
uh so
my point is
if you take a strict interpretation
gene therapy is the editing of your
genome to make you
healthier or immune or something like
this then these mrna vaccines are not
gene therapy if you take a broader
sensula to
understanding and you say that basically
the point is what gene therapy aims to
do
is to introduce a piece of information
into a body such that the body is
capable of doing something that it
couldn't do before that information was
introduced then in fact this fits
perfectly on that list and it does it at
the genetic level as opposed to like you
know vaccines are immune therapy right
like you never hear called that but
that's what they are and you know if
gene therapy is any of these bullet
points on the fda then then yeah well
let's put it this way
the problem is that a
vaccine that introduces an antigen
is not gene therapy based on the but
it's
any vaccine that is effective is immune
therapy it's it's affecting your immune
system
it's in training in fact your immune
system right effectively but i can make
it a good one that an attenuated virus
vaccine which is in fact i would argue
the gold standard of vaccines is gene
therapy by this definition and i'm not
troubled by that right just saying that
if the question is did you introduce
something in a genetic form
where the product is then causing you to
have some capability you didn't have
before right then you could make an
argument for that one and so this is why
it doesn't really matter right it
doesn't really matter but
is
introducing
a virus with genes that then causes the
virus to do something that then creates
immunity for you
right is that
vastly different or is the plasmid
example vastly different than a lipid
nanoparticle covered mrna that gets into
your cytoplasm and causes your ribosomes
to make a protein as if your nucleus had
told it to no it's not different at all
this is gene therapy at that level and
so again but again
who cares at the level of the messaging
right the point is really what ought to
alarm you is that we are doing something
for which this is a question on which
both
you could argue both sides
and what's really troubling here as we
talked about last week
is that okay
you're going to introduce something that
you know you're going to introduce a
literal genetic message yes it's rna not
dna but it's still it's a genetic
message you're going to introduce it
into the cytoplasms of cells so that
they will produce proteins that then
trigger something useful but absent a
specific targeting mechanism absence
something that tells cells
you are the cells that should pick up
this message and you are cells that
should ignore this message what happens
is you have to dump enough of the
message in that enough cells pick it up
to create enough effect to be worth
doing
but that means a lot of cells that are
not doing the body any favor by
transcribing this message are going to
pick it up
and that's the question the myocarditis
that we talked about last week might be
the hypothesis that i put on the table
last week was that the heart is picking
up these messages faithfully
transcribing them the way the designers
of the vaccines hoped they didn't think
it was going to be heart cells but they
didn't
provide the lipid nanoparticles of the
mechanism for bypassing the heart either
right so the heart picks it up
transcribes the message the immune
system looks at the heart transcribing
foreign messages and thinks that it's
virally infected and attacks and kills
some of the cells in the heart which you
can't afford to lose because it's your
heart and it's not capable of replacing
them with similar cells
right so
that's the level of the hazard is it
gene therapy it the fact that it is
arguably gene therapy means that that's
the level at which we should be having
this conversation this is not
uh an antigen that was dumped into your
uh system in order to wake up your
immune system to a pathogen this is
something much more serious and novel
than that
and that's the conversation that needs
to be had
[Music]